Hello and welcome to this next video, only interface series and we're going to be looking
at the content browse.
Right, so we're back into the editor and up to this point we have been either using the
actors that were already in the scene or we have been using the quickly add to project
button in the top here.
Now for this I would like to concentrate on the content browser.
Now the content browser can be accessed across the engine by holding down control and space
bar.
What that's going to do is that will bring up the content browser here.
Now I use the content browser a lot so I am going to click on the dock in layout and what
this is going to mean is the content browser is now added to the screen here.
If you don't like it in this location you can always drag up and place things in different
places.
You can do that with all of the windows but I'm used to it being in the bottom of the
screen like this sort of throwback to previous versions of Unreal.
So the content browser is our file navigation system much like Windows Explorer on the windows
it's going to allow us to look into different folders and see what files are there.
Now at any point for example with this MI third person call way this is a material by
right hand click you can see I can actually come over and see this file in Explorer.
Let's go show in Explorer and we can access and see the U asset files in the Windows Explorer.
Again I want to iterate to not move files around within the Windows Explorer it will work.
What it will do is break any references that connect to that asset.
Okay so let's talk about the content browser on the left hand side here we have our breakdown
of the file system we can move through it much similar to your normal file system and
on the right hand side we have what is actually in our file system.
Again you can double click on any of them and you can also double click to open up any
of the assets.
So in this case I've opened up the third person character which we haven't really touched
on how these work at this point but that is a blueprint that I've opened up.
Now there are a couple of things which are useful to know in order to navigate easily
around this.
The first thing is if I was to select something within the world for example how the cube
and I was to press control B that will navigate to that object in the browser.
The control B at any point will navigate to the specific asset in the browser so that
you can find it.
And this is really useful because at any point we can take an asset and drag it into the
world and that will create an equivalent actor if possible.
In this case these are static meshes which are models and if I was to drag one into the
world it's actually going to create a static mesh actor with the values of the static mesh
being set to the mesh that we've identified and the materials of the default material
on this asset.
Delete that and go a little bit just per cushion the delete button.
However some of these function differently.
For example if we go back to our content directory and we had somewhere in here we had a we in
the third person we had this material which is the third person cover Y.
You can see this is the color which is used on all of these assets.
Now this is not a static mesh and it's a material so that means it will dictate how a static
mesh looks.
Now in this case if I was to drag it in it would not create an actor but what it would
do is it would detect under the mouse cursor what the static mesh is and attempt to apply
the material to it.
So you can see in this case it's applied that material to the static mesh that we're using
is the floor.
I'm going to press control Z and that will undo the assigned.
So they're quite clever.
When we drag in an asset it will know what kind of asset you're dragging in and it's
going to try and apply it to the world in the most logical way.
So material would apply a material a static mesh would create a static mesh actor and
if we were to go back and into our third person character blueprint is going to spawn an instance
of the blueprint into the world like we have here.
So third person character.
So just by dragging stuff into the world that's going to make sense.
Now there are some things that don't necessarily make sense such as a game mode so that wouldn't
happen with everything.
Okay so that's dragging things into the world and that's referred to as making an instance
of the blueprint.
Now as your project becomes more complicated it might be worth knowing some more advanced
methods of navigating your content system.
So the first one is filters.
As you can see here in the top left hand corner there is an open or add filters menu.
If you jump this down or this is going to do if I go to the content directory it's going
to allow us for example to select on a filter for static meshes.
So now this is going to show me all of the static meshes which are below the content
directory and you'll also see that we get an extra window here for filters so I can
turn this on and off.
And for example if I wanted materials it's going to show me just the materials which
are below my content directory and there are and you can do that for any any clients
where you can create a custom filter.
Next up would be favorites.
At the moment here you can see we have a favorite section at the top and if we know there is
a directory which we're going to come back to a lot such as blueprints I could come in
right hand click on the directory go add to favorites.
Now we'll find under favorites and we'll be able to see the blue pinched direction allowing
us to find it quick.
Also to reinforce that if we were looking for if we had a group of them you can set the
folders to be a specific color.
In this case I'm going to set my blueprints directory to below and now it's easy to see
particular.
Finally we have collections.
Now if you come down to the bottom here what a collection is is it's going to allow us
to tag all of the assets with a specific value and then we're going to be able to filter
and see a collection of just the assets that we've tapped.
So for example if I wanted to have if I added a collection and I had a local collection
I'm going to call this meshes.
Now if I wanted to come in I'll select the static meshes and I'm going to drag into the
directory all of the meshes which are designed to put together a environment.
And now I can select that and it will just give me these meshes and I can then drag into
the world.
To reiterate what we've covered here you've got favorite directories that are going to
be assembled out moving to a different area.
You've got the directory colors to allow you to quickly see them in the browser.
Collections this allows you to tag different assets and then view only those tagged assets.
We've got the filtering system which is going to allow you to filter on different terms
usually the type of asset and that will bring us to the end of our video.
See you in the next one.